hola
[Música]
[Aplausos]
no no
[Música]
como llega con buena de 1799
pero al tenemos un poco la historia qué
hubiera pasado si hubiera tenido
instagram
hola amigos ya llegamos a cumaná estamos
aquí amigos
sí
y tu querida cómo va tu moto en la vida
esto fue algo que escribió alexander
conjuntos en una carta mientras hacía su
viaje por américa a él le encantaba
compartir sus logros por eso yo creo que
instagram lo hubiera hecho muy feliz
pues no solo sirve para formar nuestras
identidades sino también compartimos
nuestras pasiones y nuestros valores y
nuestros logros y que la gente vea lo
que estamos logrando es otra razón para
seguir haciéndolo claro esto no debería
ser la única
alexander von humboldt hizo un viaje por
casi cinco años en américa aislado de su
familia de sus amigos como lo hizo como
lo logró
bueno él amaba la naturaleza y el
conocimiento infinitamente y compartir
nunca fue su meta final sino sólo una
parte de la recompensa el aprendizaje
era lo que importaba
y es cierto en las redes sociales no
sólo se trata de compartir sino también
de aprender pero tengo dos críticas a
esta manera de aprender la primera es
en
nosotros vemos fotos y textos en las
redes sociales pero dónde quedó la
experiencia este aprendizaje
significativo
y otra crítica es las identidades y
situaciones que vemos en instagram o en
las redes sociales no son del todo
reales sino más bien son sólo una
construcción de estas donde el usuario
decide 100% que suprimir y que no por
ejemplo es muy raro que veamos que el
usuario muestre sentimientos de dolor
sufrimiento tristeza y todos estos son
parte de nuestra identidad que sólo
estamos suprimiendo
nosotros invariablemente nos vamos a
comparar con
los cuerpos las experiencias las vidas
los logros de las personas que seguimos
en nuestras redes sociales
como decía que la competencia era lo que
mantenía a los científicos motivados y
está envidia que se generaba era lo que
hacía lo que provocaba estos logros tan
trascendentes
así que yo tampoco creo que la
competencia lo que comparamos sea algo
necesariamente malo el problema no es
que no estemos comparando el problema es
con que nos estamos comparando y nos
estamos comparando con identidades
falsas llenas de huecos
el problema con esto es que
los niveles de ansiedad suben y de
depresión de hecho se comprobó que
instagram es la red social
que más aumenta en los índices de
depresión y de ansiedad en una encuesta
que se hizo a 1500 adolescentes
pero
hay una red social sólo una que se
comprobó que reduce los índices de
ansiedad y de depresión derivados de la
soledad
bueno no solo es informativa sino
también nos da una perspectiva muy
crítica y aparte nos hace sentir
entendidos pues nos podemos relacionar
con personas de nuestra generación y
como ellos lidian con sus vidas como
resuelven sus problemas etcétera
otro medio que es muy cómico y de hecho
informativo y a la vez nos hace no
tomarnos las cosas las cosas tan en
serio son los memes
por ejemplo smm tal vez se hubiera
gustado a humboldt que se sentía muy
incomprendido
pues si los jueves también nos sirven
para desarrollar un pensamiento crítico
y si sentirnos entendidos
más que nada
tenía
un par de maestros que estaban
encargados de iluminar lo que le
enseñaban que estaba bien y que estaba
mal como debía vivir su vida y entonces
a sus únicas referencias hacia el mundo
nosotros hoy en día tenemos infinitas
fuentes y por eso una opinión no nos
afecta tanto porque podemos basar
nuestra opinión en infinitas fuentes en
infinita de información y nosotros
realmente formar nuestra propia opinión
y eso es genial
pero a veces buscamos en estas fuentes
respuestas respuestas a preguntas
realmente cuyas respuestas realmente
debíamos estar buscando en nuestro
interior nadie te va a decir quién eres
nadie te va a decir por qué estás aquí
eso solo tienes que buscar
por medio de las experiencias
estamos haciendo historia nunca nadie
había logrado antes algo así recopilamos
y catalogamos más de seis miles de
plantas
estamos revolucionando la ciencia
[Música]
[Aplausos]
qué hubiera pasado si humboldt hubiera
revolucionado las ciencias hoy
subyacente igual de único igual de
especial
[Música]
[Aplausos]
no yo creo que no soy igual de única y
especial pues se hubiera comparado con
todos estos científicos que están
revolucionando las ciencias que son tan
exitosos y ni que lo culpe pues innovar
en un mundo con 7 mil millones y medio
de personas se vuelve realmente difícil
aparte el mundo está muy interconectado
y pues yo en esta plática realmente
tampoco estoy no van
pero es importante
aunque probablemente sí para eso me
invitaron pero
hay que ser realistas cuanto valor le
podemos atribuir a la innovación en un
mundo tan grande y tan interconectado
prácticamente ninguno
porque todo perdería significado
por ejemplo yo encontré mínimo 10 ted
talks hablando sobre las redes sociales
y es lo que estoy haciendo
fútbol catálogo 6.000 especies de
plantas yo tengo 10 plantas en mi azotea
y aunque no crean a veces son migración
para despertarme y aparte
estoy contribuyendo a una muy buena
causa a limpiar esta ciudad y el aire
que está contaminado
entonces
de bueno podemos decir que las redes
sociales parten de estos tres principios
innovar compartir y compararse los
cuales si lo pensamos son muy buenos nos
ayudan a desarrollarnos como personas
aparte nos mantienen informados las
redes sociales es decir nunca en toda la
historia la humanidad las personas bien
estado tan conscientes de lo que está
sucediendo en el resto del mundo
qué está pasando en la vida de nuestros
amigos en cada momento y pues todos
estos son valores practicantes buenos
entonces que me estoy quejando
ok
mundialmente pasamos dos horas y 22
minutos en las redes sociales y nosotros
los adolescentes tres lo más preocupante
es que esta cifra ha estado en aumento
es decir en 2012 era tan solo una hora y
media
así que cada vez
nos aislamos más de nuestra realidad
y tenemos menos consciencia de nuestro
cuerpo de las personas que nos rodean
y creemos que yahoo respuestas es una
fuente más confiable a nuestras
preguntas existenciales a jacko
respuestas no todas decir que es la vida
o encontrar sentido en ella o porque no
le gustas a nadie
bueno probablemente porque lo estás
preguntando en las respuestas pero
y cada vez nos aislamos más
por eso a mí me cuesta mucho trabajo
creer que el aumento en el uso de las
redes sociales sea algo positivo
así que pregunto quién cree que sus
vidas mejorarían si no usaran bueno si
disminuyen su uso en las redes sociales
ok esta es la mayoría quien cree que sus
vídeos mejorarían si no tuvieran redes
sociales puntos
ok algunos valientes
aun
pues sí
con esto llegó a que tantas te toques
tantos artículos advirtiéndonos de este
tema y nuestro uso las redes sociales de
hecho ha aumentado porque
yo no tengo idea la verdad pero
bueno yo ya dejé de usar instagram y
otra pregunta ustedes creen que humboldt
lo voy a tener tanto tiempo para pasarse
2 horas y 22 minutos en las redes
sociales obviamente ya vimos en sus
historias o sea no hubiera querido
perderse de nada
pero tal vez
tal vez
al compararse con tantas personas no
hubiera visto el sentido de nacer sus
viajes tan históricos en revolucionar
las ciencias
y tal vez este auditorio se llenó de
personas igual que igual de capaces de
originales pero que están demasiado
ocupadas comparándose cuanto así 2 horas
y 22 minutos al día con cuántas personas
y 7 mil millones y medio de personas
[Aplausos]